okay hi everyone and first of all thank
you to the organizers for inviting me
it's a pleasure to be here so i'll talk
about a problem that does use convict
optimization i'll talk about recovering
simultaneously structured objects by
recovering what i mean is essentially
solving an inverse problem where you're
given linear
equations um in an unknown and you know
that unknown has some structure and you
would like to reconstruct it based on
the linear measurements so this is joint
work with my student amin at uw and our
collaborators at celtic summit and
actually summit now is that berkeley in
fact i should update this
um and bob casivia at caltech and yonina
elder okay so um
the main problem is uh
one of uh trying to use low
dimensionality structure in a in a
useful way in many different application
areas so by low dimensional we mean that
we are interested in finding
reconstructing recovering objects that
have very few degrees of freedom even
though they appear very high dimensional
and these guys these kinds of structures
arise very naturally in many
applications from signal processing to
machine learning to system
identification and we'll see some
examples
and the basic premise is that we would
like to have convict optimization
methods in order to be computationally
efficient to recover the low dimensional
object from limited measurements and
limited here is important because in
this talk we will be interested in
characterizing how many measurements do
i need or how much information do i need
for the convex method to be able to
reconstruct the object of interest so we
are interested in what in machine
learning is called sample complexity
balance
we'll see what kind of measurements we
are talking about
so first i'll start by talking about uh
the specific types of structures i'm
interested in this talk are simultaneous
structures of say what they are and
where they arise then i'll do a quick
review of recovering a single type of
structure so that type of problem arises
in compressed sensing low rank recovery
and
by now very classic problems that many
of you would have seen but i'll just do
a very quick review
then the main result i want to show is
the fundamental limitation of combining
convex penalties when you have
simultaneous structure if you combine
the different convex penalties does it
work or not and what's the limitation
and i'll show a result that actually
does hold for a very variety of
different measurements on the object
initial result was based on gaussian but
now we can actually it holds for more
than that
um
and there's a related problem i'll
mention if there is time and we'll
summarize after that okay so what do we
mean by structure let's first talk about
structure
what i mean is for example vectors that
are sparse that comes up in compressed
sensing uh that is vector can be of size
n but it only has k non-zero entries
where k is much less than n
the another example is vectors that have
groups of non-zero
elements
that's called group sparse vectors
that so um actually as you as you have
probably seen in these literature there
is there are norms that are associated
with these structures so for example for
sparse vectors in order to encourage a
solution to be sparse you would minimize
an l1 or for
group sparse vectors you would minimize
sums of l2 norms of the groups that's
called the one two norm
um this idea extends to low rank
matrices as you've probably seen in some
examples coming up in areas like
collaborative filtering recommendation
systems also in signal processing in the
problem of phase retrieval
reconstructing signals phase given
amplitude measurements and for this to
encourage a matrix to be low rank the
norm that's mostly used there are also
other norms or penalties but the one
that's mostly used is nuclear norm or
trace norm or chaton1 or
some of the singular values of the
matrix
there are other types of structure for
example the one that anima was just
talking about that is suppose you want
to reconstruct an object that is a
summation of a low rank part and a
sparse part so here i'm not talking
about uh separating them but let's say
you want to reconstruct the sum the
total sum and this comes up in several
areas like pca with outliers or
graphical models with hidden variables
and so on and the objective function or
the penalty that is used to encourage
such structure would be typically is
infinite convolution of the norms which
is nothing but basically the sum of
nuclear norm of the l part and one
norm of the the sparse part so you can
just combine these norms so these well
understood norms can be combined in this
way and it
will show how these uh work
in terms of sample complexity now let's
move on to some newer examples
of structure
the one that i'm going to focus on this
is an example of the type of structure
i'll focus on this talk is simultaneous
structure so for example a matrix that's
simultaneously sparse and low rank
one matrix is sports and rank at the
same time where does this come up it
comes up in sparse phase retrieval or
actually explain that application
and it's also related to the problem of
sparse pca you want to do principle
component analysis but you want the
eigenvectors themselves to be sparse
also what's known as quadratic compress
sensing you want to reconstruct a sparse
vector given quadratic measurements
and for in order to encourage sparse and
low rank you would imagine you would use
l1 norm and nuclear norm each of these
two structures comes with its own norm
that encourages it
another example of simultaneous
structure that's more recent is
trying to find low rank sensors
by rank here we mean the tucker ranks or
tensors with low tucker rank which is
the rank that depends on the rank of the
unfolded matrices
of the tensor and there the penalty that
you could minimize would be nuclear norm
of the unfolded matrices so it's the
rank of each unfolding relax each of
these ranks to nuclear will get a
combination of nuclear norms
another type of example is
signals that are simultaneously sparse
and piecewise constant
in signal processing then again you have
two different structures and this has a
name actually in applied statistics it's
called fused lasso
and uh for sparsity you could use a one
norm for being piecewise constant you
can minimize the one norm of changes
from every entry to the next which is
called the total variation norm
so these are examples in which more than
one structure showed up
one object with more than one structure
okay so these are things we're
interested in the elastic
in this report
l1 and l2 but i guess l2 is not really
that assuming
yes um it kind of fits but l2 is not
that interesting because it's not it
doesn't really help with sample
complexity much so we focus more on
structures that really do reduce the
dimension
but yeah in theory it does
okay so one application this is one
application laid out it's specifically
for sparse and low rank matrices so when
is it that i want a variable to be both
sparse and do rank and this application
comes from signal processing it's called
the phase retrieval problem it's a
classic problem where you have a light
source you have an unknown object and
you have an image plane in which you can
measure the light intensity after
diffraction the pattern is formed and
the intensity is measured and from the
light intensity measurements which
actually look like this so absolute
value
of inner product between the sensing
vector and the desired signal is
measured so you have a bunch of these
measurements m of them and you would
like to reconstruct x naught
and um so this this set of measurements
are not linear however you can linearize
them with a trick that you are very
familiar with which is just lifting so
just square this square both sides of
this and you get
basically something that looks like this
so a i ai transpose x naught x naught
transpose just rename x not excellent
transpose which is a rank one matrix as
a new variable x and then now i have
something that's linear in x so i just
linearize it by lifting um but i need to
require this x to be rank one
for it to be exact and so that's why
i have linear equalities in a variable
that has to be rank one psc et cetera
um
however we also often have another piece
of information so this problem has been
studied for example in this reference
but often we know that this signal is
also sparse
so if x naught is also sparse then
capital x is outer product of sparse
vectors so it's a sparse and rank one
matrix in fact it just has one block one
non-zero block inside it
um there are many other applications of
very similar kind of sparse and low rank
matrix one of them as i mentioned is a
very simple case of sparse principle
component analysis so suppose you're
interested in just the top eigenvector
you want to approximate your matrix with
a rank 1 matrix but the top eigenvector
you also wanted to encourage it to be
sparse
so this is very similar to the previous
problem and actually there are many
other applications in which the same
lifting technique is used applied to
sparse vectors
and another paper i saw that's using the
same idea is in this one
but there's also more
okay so these were motivating examples
what is the problem what do we mean by
recovering structures question
uh what we mean by recovering structure
what we mean is this so there are
actually two problems we are interested
in but the second problem i probably
won't get to that's at the end of the
talk the first one is reconstructing x
naught given compressed measurements and
what i mean by compressed measurements
is just a linear operator acting on the
signal x naught so it's from r n to r m
giving m measurements so i can also just
simply write it as matrix multiplication
the a is a big matrix of size m by n
so i'm given the uh
the y vectors or the measurements and i
know the structure of x naught but i
don't know x naught i want to construct
a problem that finds extent
and the denoising problem is a simpler
problem in which you are given a noisy
version of x naught you want to get rid
of noise
so in the case of compressed measurement
a question that's very much of interest
sample complexity question is how many
measurements do we need to be able to
exactly reconstruct x1
what's the smallest m that we need m is
the number of measurements here
and for this denoising case the question
of how does mean square error behave is
an important question
so some familiar examples of this and
this is review known structures suppose
my object of interest has only one
structure for example
sparsity and so if i know x naught is k
sparse
what i want to solve is this problem
find the sparsest vector subject to ax
equals ax naught
um l0 norm that's sparsity and we ask
the question how many measurements do we
need well how big should m be here how
many equality constraints and the answer
is order k
order k uniquely determines the k-sparse
vector solution of this program will be
with high probability over well so high
probability here is because these a's
are chosen randomly so let's say the
matrix a is chosen uh with iad gaussian
entries
um then with high probability over that
choice
we need only order k measurements
but this problem is mp hard non-convex
this is this convex relaxation you
replace l0 norm with l1 norm how many
measurements does this need
the theory that goes back to candice
taro donahoe and others shows that is k
log n essentially so all that we lost in
terms of sample complexity from the
non-convex problem to the convex problem
was just a log n factor so it's pretty
good the convex problems sample
complexity is not much more than
non-convex
with my probability here means means
this goes exponentially to one
proportional to the number of
measurements
so same thing holds for low rank
matrices so suppose the desired object
you want to reconstruct is a low rank
matrix
n by n matrix of rank r
and i want to solve this problem find
the lowest rank matrix that agrees with
measurements how many observations do we
need is order n times r dimension of the
matrix times the rank
um convex relaxation is going to
minimize the nuclear norm or trace norm
and interestingly the number of
measurements it means if a is gaussian
is order n times r same order we didn't
lose anything
so so it's pretty interesting these
norms work really well in the sense of
sample complexity
so now we want to study the case in
which we have an x not that has more
than one structure and then we want to
write down a convex problem that tries
to reconstruct x naught and we want to
see what's the sample complexity so
first of all what kind of optimization
problem will i write so suppose x naught
has several structures each of them
comes with a structure promoting norm so
sparsity laurentness etc
and what kind of optimization problem
should i write well typically you would
combine these norms in some fashion with
a
composition function h where h is a
convex and non-decreasing in each
argument function so that the overall f
is a convex function this h does not
have any other restriction other than
other than this
um one example of such an h is if you
take just linear combination of
individual norms with some
regularization parameters landos or
another option is you take a piecewise
or pointwise maximum of the norms with
some parameters alphas so these are two
examples of h but you can think of any
other age as well so combine these norms
and minimize them subject to
measurements and the question is
we hope that the number of measurements
this needs is much much lower than each
individual structure would require
because now we are looking for an object
that at the same time has several
structures so space of such objects is
very small
degrees of freedom should be very small
so let's study this optimization program
independent of the age
here is a way to think of these
multi-objective optimization problems so
suppose we only have two norms this is
normal number one norm number two and i
take x's that satisfy the constraints
and then i put a point where
the value of that particular extra
satisfies constraint corresponds to
those norm 1 and 2. so i can generate a
set that
that is
the set of all feasible x's
um how they look on the norm plot and
then you can actually take the boundary
of the set the
lower left boundary of this set which
will be the pareto optimal set so here
i've plotted several sets because
depending on how many measurements you
have you get different regions so this m
this number of measurements was too low
for recovering this x naught this x
naught does not lie on the pareto curve
now this m is good because x naught does
lie on the pareto curve
um so if x naught lies on the pareto
curve on this trade-off curve then there
are many ways to reconstruct it for
example i can take a linear combination
of objectives and that forms a line
where the slope of the line gives me the
lambda
and that line if it hits at the right
point so by tuning the lambda i can
reconstruct x or i can take the
pointwise max that would be looking at
something like that so if xlt is on the
boundary there are many ways to recover
it if it's not on the boundary then none
of these problems are going to recover
it no matter what the tuning is so we
are interested in that m how big should
that m be
so the summary of results i will show
first is that we show that this combined
complex penalties the program i showed
you has a fundamental limitation
and this negative result that says
the number of measurement scales not as
good as we want actually holds for a lot
of different classes of measurement
operators
um it's easiest at first we had shown it
for
gaussian iid but actually holds for
other ones as well i'll show you
how
you can write the proof in an easy way
that applies to all of these
um and then we can specialize the result
to the case of sparse and low rank
matrices to concretely see how much this
gap can be
when you combine individual penalties
compared to the best possible
penalty
okay so the question is this this is the
same optimization program as before when
does this program combining the
individual norms subject to the linear
measurements
um we want a negative result so when
does this fail to give the correct x
naught as the solution correct excellent
is this x naught that appeared here
that has
these s different structures let's say
okay so here's a theorem this one is
deterministic it just says that um
let's normalize x naught so any any
vector that has a bar on it means that
it's divided by its l2 norm so
normalized with l2
we have this inequality
if this holds then x naught is not a
minimizer of this optimization problem
so
this inequality
basically says that if the inner product
between the sub gradients of the
function f and the desired x naught
are all of them bigger than some
quantity that depends on the measurement
matrix
then x naught is the
is not the minimizer
so this notation is the sub differential
which is the set of all subgradients of
the function f at point x naught
because f is typically non-smooth if it
was smooth it would be just gradient
but now we have a set of subgradients if
it's not so
so let's look a little bit more
carefully at that inequality
if i look at the
left-hand side
well right-hand side if i look at that
way this side of the inequality only
depends on x naught that's the desired
signal we want to construct and f the
objective function it doesn't depend on
the measurements so this thing is a
geometric quantity essentially that has
to do with the structure of f and its
subdifferential
now this side
depends on the a
the measurement matrix
which we typically take to be random
from different ensembles and it depends
on x naught which is the desired signal
so if i can actually lower bound this
side by some quantity that captures the
structure of my problem
and that would be a geometric quantity
and if i upper bound this
by for example random matrix theory
because if a is a random matrix this is
just the norm of the matrix column sum
of the norms and this is the um
sigma min
and these quantities are very well
understood for many classes of random
matrices so if i upper bound this one
lower bound this one i can get an
inequality that tells me how big this m
should be
so that's what we are going to do
the right hand side we argue that the
right hand side for getting a negative
result the right hand side cannot be
made very small so we would like to push
this down but we cannot
because the subgradients actually are
more or less aligned with the desired
signal and their inner product is not
going to become very small they're not
going to be
close to orthogonal or anything this is
the left-hand side
yes
so defense depends which way you're
facing
the whole the whole right hand left is
messed up but
so this side is the deterministic side
this is the random side
um yeah so for many of the many random
ensembles this part this side is easy to
bound
so this is what we're going to do
in fact if you actually know random
matrix theory for many matrices for
example iid random gaussian this ratio
is going to scale as square root m over
n
this is probably a familiar ratio a lot
of
uh
random matrix uh quantities uh
four different ensembles scale like that
so if you put these together
so okay let me first talk about this
side so to lower bound that
geometrically what we do is that
we define a quantity that
whose geometric interpretation is
basically a correlation between a vector
and a set
so first let's look at this
rho is a correlation between vector x
and a set s which is the smallest inner
product normalized you can also think of
it as having to do with the cosine of
the angle
so in this figure if x is my desired
vector and s is the desired set this s
star is the point that makes the
smallest inner product
it's in the set and has the smallest
inner product with x
um so this row quantity has a lower
bound so if you look at this actually if
you apply it to
the
sub subdifferential set so we are
interested in finding that quantity
for the sub sub differential of f at x
naught
and when you plug in a summation of
norms or a function of norms that we had
before
it will be lower bounded by this
quantity which is the minimum of kappa i
and kappa i's are nothing but the ice
norm of the desired signal divided by
lipschitz constant of the ice norm
lipstick's constant shows how fast the
norm changes
so it's kind of a global constant
everywhere in fact to bound this
quantity we needed it locally but it's
fine it's bounded by the global constant
um let me show you how we do this that's
actually not hard
so first
the inequality i had written comes from
the optimality condition of the
optimization problem that's not very
hard to write you write down the
optimality condition project and then
bound norms and use triangle inequality
and then in order to link it to the
kappa min that i mentioned in order to
link it to the norm of x naught over the
ellipses constant of the norm
um we observe that any subgradient of f
can be written as the sum of individuals
of gradients so gi is a subgradient only
for the norms nor i
um the overall sub gradient is always a
linear combination with non-negative
constants of the gi's
so if you plug that in and also observe
that the inner product between the
signal and the ice
sub gradient is nothing but the norm
the ice norm of that signal
we get that the inner product that we
are interested in is just this
now this g is not normalized let's
normalize y g divided by l2 norm of g l2
norm of g by triangle inequality is less
than this
uh summation of w i l i i are the
ellipses constant of each of the norms
so when we plug it in this is bigger
than this bigger than this and this is
the so the sums are bounded by the
individual terms bigger than the minimum
of this ratio which is nothing but kappa
min
so kappa min is a geometric quantity
that's lower bounds the
that side of the inequality
okay so okay so now we have that so
let's look back at this inequality we
have a bound on here that's geometric
that depends on the geometry of the
problem now let's bound this side
okay so for that side all we needed to
do was to look at some random matrix
theory results including very well known
classical results
work well for example um tutorial notes
by roman merten very very helpful
um the first class would be gaussian
measurements if the a matrix is
entry-wise iid gaussian
zero mean unit variance
then
x naught will not be a minimizer of the
recovery program with high probability
again probability exponential
if m is less than a constant times n
ambient dimension times kappa mean
squared
so sample complexity of the problem is
order of n kappa mean squared
so it's very general
it's for any sets of structures you have
you just have to compute this one
parameter kappa min which comes from the
geometry of the sub differential and
then you have a sample complexity bound
and maybe a more interesting one is um
the case where these measurements are
not
ioid gaussian
in practice a type of measurement that's
very much of interest is that if you
sample entries of an object so for
example you have a low rank matrix and
you only observe a subset of the entries
of the matrix and
so then your sampling operator is
nothing but sampled rows of the identity
matrix
just reads off entries and that sampling
operator is um often a bit harder to
analyze but in this case the same
negative result does hold for that
um with we need one more assumption on
the x naught and that is that the true
signal
uh normalized with l2 norm has to have a
bounded infinity norm the infinity norm
has to be constant so this is kind of
incoherence condition for these signals
but once you have your exon is
incoherent
you can show that if you start from an a
matrix that is sampled rules of identity
even if it has repetition if it um
you can get rid of the repeated rows and
construct another matrix that is a hat
and still the inequality does work in
the in the correct way
so we have that this quantity which is
the same as before with a hat instead of
a
is also scaling as square root of m over
n
which is similar
concentration result than what we had
for gaussian which actually leads to the
similar
sample complexity bound that is n kappa
min squared so this n kappa mean square
this
seems like it's pretty universal and
it's a lower bound by the way because we
started from a sufficient condition for
the failure of the problem
to give an upper bound is a bit harder
in the case of gaussians we got an upper
bound as well but i think the point is
even shown well with this lower bound
because it just says all of these are
bad it's a negative result
so let's look at some specific examples
what happens if i apply this result for
just k-sports vectors using l1 or
the ellipsis constant of l1 norm is
square root n
um
the norm uh
the basically the l1 norm of an l2
normalized signal that is k-sports is
going to be square root k
and the n kappa squared the sample
complexity is order k
so this does agree with what we know for
k-sparse vectors their degrees of
freedom is k
this result also tells you you need
order k at least order k measurements we
know that the correct scaling is k log n
or k log n over k
but you need at least k
for um a matrix that has only k non-zero
columns
you can use the l12 norm
these are the quantities and the sample
complexes k times d
again expected it's a degree of freedom
you have sizes d and you have k non zero
columns
for a rank r matrix use nuclear norm
these are the lipschitz constant and the
normalized
nuclear norm and the n kappa squared
would be r times d so rank times
dimension
so again i agree with the best known
results for low rank matrix refer
recovery but once you combine things so
i have a sparse and low rank matrix
then if i use a combination of nuclear
norm and l1 norm
what i get will be
would be minimum of k squared and r
times d
and for example if r which is the rank
is one if i just want to reconstruct a
rank one matrix is minimum of k squared
and d
um and that actually is not the best you
would imagine because the degrees of
freedom on actually what i mean here by
kkr is that the matrix is rank r
and it has only a k by k non-zero block
inside it
per muted it means you don't gain
anything from the two structure you
might as well just focus on one of them
and
you don't get anything from the level
exactly exactly
basically it's just the minimum of the
two so this is k squared because the
number of non-zero entries in this
matrix because this kyk block is k
squared so basically it says that if you
individually minimize l1 norm and
individually minimize nuclear norm and
just compare them to the best result
it's the same order as combining them
yeah that's exactly the point combining
the norms doesn't buy you anything more
than
the best of the individual norms
so and actually we have some numerical
simulation that uh that showed this
here's a here's another way to depict it
and here actually we looked at the l12
norm so suppose the same same matrix one
we want to reconstruct it's a k by k
block inside the big d by d matrix
and um one might say well you should use
l one two norm because you know there's
a lot of zero columns and you can
certainly do that so minimize nuclear
norm plus a one two norm and even if you
do know for example the matrix is
positive semi-definite
even if that's the case in some
applications it is
the this convex relaxation sample
complexity is still order nr
and the best possible which for example
you can find if you were able to
minimize these non-convex penalties the
number of non-zero columns
of x and x transpose plus the rank of x
if you were able to minimize this the
sample complexity would be k n plus k
times r which is good which is the real
degrees of freedom
um real degrees of freedom is actually
order k times r but this is pretty close
so there is a gap between the best
non-con what non-convex can do and what
convex um relaxation does so this shows
the convex lysation is far from what is
potentially far from what's possible
and when we simulate this we see this
behavior so we took some matrices and
this pink curve shows if we only
minimize a one norm
to recover a sparse and orange matrix
and let's see
and the black one is only trace with pst
constraint which is equivalent to
nuclear norm if you know the matrix is
pst
and so you get this curve for l1 and
this curve for nuclear norm and if
you're minimizing both of them together
you get some combination of them
basically you get
for example
this red one is l1 trace and pst combine
together so it is scaling at first like
the
um like this one
and then like the nuclear norm one but
it's not really gaining you much
it's picking the best of the two
essentially
so that agrees with the theory
and we have a lot more examples in which
we do the try to get the phase
transition and so on as well empirically
but you can't see the paper for those
um let me stop and see if there are any
questions
um
no actually there's one more problem i
want to mention but there is time yeah
yes yeah
but um okay there's a related problem i
want to just briefly mention because it
shows that this bottleneck that we saw
isn't really a function of this linear
inverse problem linear measurements etc
it comes up in other situations as well
so the second problem is one of the
noising
um suppose x naught is again the desired
signal and it has s different structures
each of them with its own norm and we
are just given a noisy version of x
naught so x naught plus noise where here
noise is iid gaussian zero mean uh
variance of noise is sigma squared
and this is a problem that has been
studied in statistics quite a bit
there is this typical denoising program
which minimizes the difference between
what you have observed and the variable
and it adds a regularization term that
induces the structures that you
that you know this signal has so here we
are using a linear combination of the
norms
suppose we do that so this denoising
program
has the same bottleneck in what sense
typically when people talk about this
denoising program there's a statistical
quantity of interest which is the mean
squared error
uh
called also mse risk which is defined as
follows if you take the expected value
of the difference of the estimate that's
the answer of this optimization problem
so what i mean by x hat
of this guy is if y was equal to gamma x
naught plus z and i plugged it in this
program that x dot will come out so what
came out minus the true signal i wanted
to reconstruct which is gamma x naught
so gamma here is actually a scalar
that's quantified signal to noise ratio
i could have equivalently written
this in terms of the sigma squared and
lets the variance of the noise vary but
i want to see what's the worst error can
i have overall signal to noise ratios
and you usually want to bound this error
now
for this program where you're combining
the different norms we can show that
this
mean square error which is a function of
these landos
but even for the best tuning of the
landos
is not better so it's lower bounded by
the minimum of the individual
again the same as before so for example
the
performance is order wise the same as
the single best norm
can you elaborate on why did you choose
this particular diffusion because like
the classical definition is statistics
isn't this
of the msc right
well for this denoising programs this
this has been used but lsa you can
define a different way so this one
basically is the worst case error over
all the noise scalings
so this is the signal you recover this
is the true one that you wanted this is
the l2 norm it's expected value
because the noise is random and then
you're saying the largest overall
possible signal to noise ratios or all
possible noise variances and maybe it is
a little bit strange but it appears in
in some literature maybe not everyone is
interested
as gamma gets smaller there is less
signal compared to the noise
yes
but in fact it's one thing that's weird
about this notion is that um this
maximum is achieved as the noise goes to
zero or the signal goes to infinity snr
goes to infinity so that's actually the
hardest according to this measure
because then both the signal and the
error or bad the ratios
but so there are different measures so
different literature might be interested
in different ones but this one has shows
definitely the same behavior
um perhaps we can analyze other notions
of mse as well
the interesting thing is this one is
directly related to the same geometric
quantities of sub differentials and
angles that we had in the previous
problem
so it's interesting that the the issue
comes up in this problem as well the
same bottleneck holds when you combine
different norms in this problem as well
okay so um there are more details for
this denoising problem but i didn't want
to get into it so that was just a brief
summary of that one
okay so we talked about simultaneously
structured models and we looked at for
example taking weighted sum of norms
and people do this in applications all
the time when you have multiple
structures you just take a combination
of these different norms and minimize it
and you're hoping or practitioners
actually expect that that would result
in the best possible uh reconstruction
with minimum information
so so far people use this in practice a
lot but there was no performance theory
but once you write down the theory
you'll see that combined convex penalty
actually has a fundamental gap both for
recovery sample complexity and for
denoising at least for these two
problems i showed you and that the lower
bound holds for various kinds of
measurements as long as you can bound
that quantity of l2 norm of ax naught
over sigma min of a transpose
which can be bounded by
random matrix theory for many classes
and it's interesting that it allows us
this realization that that's the
quantity you need to bound allows us to
apply this negative result for things
like matrix completion or tensor
completion and in fact in tensor
completion it will give new results that
people haven't had before
it also allows us to apply it i didn't
actually give the details but you can
also do it for quadratic measurements
which goes back to that phase retrieval
example i mentioned in the beginning
what i mean by quadratic measurement is
um
this one so here the measurements were
quadratic in x naught therefore the
measurement matrix was actually itself
an outer product a iai transpose
so this one needs a different analysis
this whole a matrix is neither gaussian
nor
the other distributions we saw but if
you assume a vector itself is gaussian
and therefore the matrix is outer
products of gaussians still things do
work out
and you still get a similar
concentration
um again that's you just have to find
the right results and bound this
quantity
so it works for all of these
measurements
measurement ensembles address different
kinds of applications
and um we also have some tight upper
bounds on required measurements but only
for the gaussian case
so these
values that we get for the gaussian are
actually tight for example for the
sports and or rank matrix for that
specific case
um
now this brings up one question and that
is if i have an object that has several
structures what's the best thing to do
then if it's not a good idea to just
combine the norms can i do something
better and in theory yes what you should
do is you have to identify what are the
correct
units or atoms that your object is made
of when you take those structures all
that all together into account
so for example for sports and low rank
matrices that would be outer product of
k-sports vectors so if these are your
units then you have to build a norm
or a penalty that
is based on that and there is a very
nice paper by venkat pablo ben and alan
wilski which shows how to do that a
general general theory however it's not
always computationally
feasible to
actually compute that ideal norm so that
norm if you can compute it will give you
the best sample complexity at least for
gaussian measurements but it may be mp
hard to compute itself for example
that's the case for sports and low rank
for these uh
outer product of sparse vectors so that
remains the question then remains open
in cases where you cannot find the
correct atomic norm it's still open what
should one do
perhaps some kind of relaxations to try
to bridge this gap
and there may be interesting connections
between this result i presented and some
interesting
results on sparse pca and cluster
detection problems in graphs because
over there there's a regime in which
this bounds that are similar to this
minimum of k squared and n do exist but
i don't yet know if there's a connection
or not
and here are references so this is our
main paper that's on the archive and
we've updated it in august uh this year
so uh the proofs are much simpler than
the previous version
and this one is a short paper that deals
with the denoising
thank you very much